ce n'est donc que pour demain à peu près
à cette même heure que nous connaîtrons
les nouveaux ministres de raymond barre
les secrétaires d'état seront nommés
ultérieurement et le conseil des
ministres s'en trouve donc reporté à
jeudi matin toute la journée s'est
passée au téléphone et nos informations
sont donc limités et emballé de
portières pratiquement tous les
personnages importants du régime se sont
vus aujourd'hui les uns chez les autres
et parfois même deux fois dans la
journée
10 heures ce matin raymond parent arrive
au palais de l'elysée pour s'entretenir
avec le président de la république de la
formation du nouveau gouvernement
l'entretien dure 40 minutes et valéry
giscard d'estaing charge son premier
ministre de former sa nouvelle équipe
junior allemand a pour première tâche de
poursuivre l'effort de redressement
économique et financier et ma nomination
comme premier ministre montre bien que
la politique entreprise sera poursuivie
elle a également souffert m'a également
pour tâche
de mettre au point un programme
d'actions n'ont pas d'action démagogique
comme le dit ce matin mais et d'une
action efficace
pour prêter de certains problèmes qui se
posent aux français
je crois que cette action doit être
inspiré par la préoccupation qu'a
exprimé le président la république hier
soir c'est à dire
d'expliquer aux français
et qu'il y à un choix qui peut être
dangereux pour la france et pour
eux-mêmes et 2
prendre en considération tous les
efforts qui seront faits pour que les
français puissent effectuer un bon choix
puis le chef de l'état reçoit alain
poher le président du sénat edgar faure
le président de l'assemblée nationale et
enfin jacques chirac à midi précise le
maire de paris et râpez les marches du
perron pour rester 55 minutes en tête à
tête avec le président jacques chirac
ressortira et souriant qu'à son arrivée
laissant un mot pour les journées